baby okay living on the latest in the  Kylie Jenner and Travis Scott breakup  news source tells et the pair hasn't  been together as a couple for about a  month but they're on good terms the  source adds that things have been hot  and cold since their last breakup and  they haven't been able to fully get on  the same page if you'll remember Kylie  supposedly found out about Travis  messaging another girl on Instagram a  while back though he denied ever  cheating now our source says rebuilding  the trust has been hard for Kylie  regardless the priority for the pair is  their daughter stormy she takes more  after you or Travis um she is the  perfect mixture of both of us she's  definitely like a little rager she loves  music as for whether or not Travis and  Kylie will reconcile our source says  quote they're both open to getting back  together in the future  [Music]  [Applause]